good look at the hoover dam from the
water ted yes it's good weather for
boating to go see it and it's great
weather right now to go
not so much this weekend though oh
you're changing it on us
here's the funny thing when i did that
first weather when i told you about that
20 degree temperature drop you should
see tirson's reaction right
she was shocked but that's the shock
that everyone had at home to when they
saw that too so thank you for for
letting us know about that kj outside
right now though it's gorgeous right
yeah gorgeous outside i say that because
with the lighter winds and the
temperatures in the high 70s all right
it just feels perfect out there we're
going to keep this going for now
but unfortunately it's not going to last
all week all right as we do expect some
changes very soon
man so nice out there flow facts all
right so we know we're going to reach
our first 80 degree day
in the forecast this week so we want to
let you know the earliest 80 degree day
okay that was on february 1st 2003 the
high was 81 degrees that was the
earliest the latest 80 degree day was
april 23 1941
the high was 83 degrees we put that on
social media too for for you to share
with everyone as well as we are already
seeing 80s right now in some
neighborhoods not officially but we are
seeing it right now areas like sky
canyon and centennial let's look at you
80 degrees right now 77 for spring
valley 78 north las vegas along with
aliante or 80 degrees also sunrise manor
whitney ranch 80 as well southern
highlands 77 78 for henderson still
another comfortable day out there 76
right now for indian springs 80 already
for mesquite 82 laughlin 85 for death
valley they're closing in close to 90
degrees this week there's your jet
stream up and over us right now and
that's keeping us dry and
clear of any type of storms but it's
deflecting all those showers and that
plume of moisture all the way in the
pacific northwest where they're getting
some flooding there in seattle meanwhile
we will stay dry for now but the rain
chances do go up by the time we get to
friday and saturday here's why we have
two systems one on friday that will
approach and look at this increased
shower chances on friday we'll even get
some snow in the mountains and on
saturday one will die from the north
this will be a colder one all right so
the snow levels will drop to 4 000 feet
so yes more snow in the mountains we'll
keep our eye also on those showers
chances for saturday as well and then
sunday mountain chances still will
remain the best chances like we said are
going to be on friday and saturday and
that's still about a 23 percent chance
we'll keep our eye on monday as well 50
degrees overnight
a very nice evening we'll call it
comfortable because we're in the high
70s right now the evening is still quite
nice 77 for tomorrow warm and so nice
tomorrow with those light winds expected
again here your highs throughout our
neighborhoods mid to high 70s for
tomorrow closer to 80 for green valley
also for sunrise manor nellis at 78 73
for summerlin and then highs outside the
valley close to 90 for you in death
valley look at that 89 degrees there 87
in laflin those will be our warmest
neighborhoods 74 for you in para here is
your 8 day forecast you ready for this
tomorrow nice thursday
wind but it'll be 81 degrees after that
nearly a 20 degree temperature drop with
chances for showers and also
wind as well for a few days
that is your most accurate forecast send
it back to you